hi everyone in 2019 modern warfare
changed everything and on october 28th
we usher in a new era of call of duty
with the launch of modern warfare 2.
we are back we are bigger and we are
bringing the entire team
price
gaz soap alejandro
and of course ghost we needed a stage
big enough to debut call of duty in a
whole new way
inspired by the world we're about to
enter
oil rigs cargo ships and staggering odds
are just the beginning
here is modern warfare 2.
[Music]
ship is visual
actual we're set guppy get to work
all shadows that miss was on this
platform
i want full containment
through
okay room clear coming up
[Music]
12.
[ __ ] door
we're moving to the main deck what's
your status boarding the ship with
shadow three now roger
eyes
there's no
pad time we're moving to secure coverage
come on
move to the halifax
[Music]
clear
open
you have your orders son stop that
launch
[Music]
secure those controls stop this vessel
yeah how do we board
take the ramps
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile controls are on the bridge
have to stop the lawn
copy that
perfect reloading
[Music]
between them
we're pushing towards the entry now copy
that
that crowd got the bridge entry
the door securely bridge entry
check it controls are internal
all right stand back
shadow one going explosive on bridges
three two one execute
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta
that's what we're talking about and
joining us now up from long beach
johanna great to see you how's
everything it's great thanks uh great to
have you with us and also jeff from uh
infinity ward so
we saw the first game play thanks for
that extended sequence looks incredible
uh jeff tell us a bit about that mission
uh where is that set in the game what
are we seeing there absolutely so um
first of all we're really excited to
welcome back uh captain john price and
uh
uh gaz uh garrick um
you know they're not they're not
actually in what we just saw today but
uh they're returning members from 141
and then the other two characters that
were you may recognize from the older
franchise that we're reimagining are uh
simon ghost riley and uh of course uh
soap john mctavish um and then a couple
other new characters in here that we're
really excited uh that we got to uh
create for this game um
first uh commander philip graves and uh
mexican special forces uh colonel
alejandro and alejandro i gotta say
we're it's a character we're really
excited about he's a guy who's super
capable and a guy who's just as
important as test course 141. um but as
far as the level's concerned um you know
this i got a shout out to iw you know
this was a tremendous collaboration
across all of the the different uh
disciplines as you saw everybody coming
together some really uh motivated devs
here and uh you know you saw the the
wind and the uh animations and the
awesome sound design and of course our
new water tech which is actually pushing
the boat in different directions it's
creating a physically dynamic
environment allowing for the cover you
were seeing in certain cases you could
be behind cover and then suddenly that
cover would shift and leave you exposed
but it also leaves the enemy exposed
creating this emergent gameplay
so again i'm i'm very excited just can't
wait that i'm so excited that we get to
show it off today and that's just a hint
of where things are going to go uh
johanna tell us a bit about call of duty
overall modern warfare 2 obviously you
know we're so excited that it's back
this year but you've got lots going on
across holiday what can we expect from
you guys this year yeah we um first of
all thanks for having us here we're just
so excited for october 28th
it's such a big moment not just for
modern warfare 2 and everything that
jeff and the team at infinity ward have
built but it really marks the step
change what we're calling a
transformational moment for the entire
franchise you're going to see
incredible rendering incredible graphics
all the things just within the game
itself built all on one shared engine
now
across war zone and modern warfare 2
going forward of course there's a lot of
chatter and interest about the new war
zone experience we're affectionately
calling it war zone 2.0 um there will be
um a stand-alone experience of war zone
for current existing
players as well so we're going to sort
of feed the entire community there but
all eyes on the 28th
and again i think the collaboration's
just been incredible everybody's so
excited for task force 141
um warzone coming to mobile as well for
players on the go
we're on steam as you know i mean so
it's just a big moment and there's going
to be a lot more to come in the in the
months to follow well before we we leave
we got to ask a little bit about war
zone 2 i know we just you know we're
showing game play here on this but can
you tell us anything there's a little it
seems like there's a little bit of a
tease maybe in the trailer yesterday
yeah when we're seeing that from the
community we love when the fans can pick
up some things um some chatter about
maybe seeing high-rise and other
elements but we will get into the
details of war zone 2.0 for sure it will
be an extension of the modern warfare 2
universe so all the more reason why we
think this game this moment is is such
an important uh title for all of us
looking looking ahead and like we said
we're having a bold vision around the
entire future for the franchise so we're
in we're in position we're really
excited all right well we're looking
forward to october thanks so much for
giving us a first look at the gameplay
call of duty modern warfare 2. thanks
johanna and jeff
all right well we've got lots more
summer game fest still to go and now